24 people lost their lives on nevada
roadways last month almost all of them
right here in clark county now while
that number is down from this time last
year some insist this community can do
better sasha lofta spoke with a local
mother who lost her son in a crash and
she joins us now live with more on her
message sasha
denise and brian this is the
intersection where 12-year-old johnny
smith lost his life about three years
ago when he was just walking home from
school deadly crashes like this just
keep happening in the valley so his mom
wants to warn others and help them
understand the worst can happen
johnny smith lost his life before it
could ever truly start she was a ray of
sunshine the 12 year old was hit and
killed by a car going nearly twice the
speed limit in 2019 right here in the
southwest valley every time i see
something like that it brings me back
now nearly three years since johnny's
unexpected death his mom susan wants to
see safer roads it's frustrating because
i see it continues to happen january's
fatal traffic report from nevada state
police shows 24 people lost their lives
on state roads with 21 right here in
clark county the top contributing
factors impairment and speeding we have
to be aware of that so we can do
something about it sheriff joe lombardo
also addressed the issue during his
state of the department address
wednesday citing 2021 as one of the
worst on record we had an eight percent
increase in fatal accidents
14 year high
for the state of nevada their statistics
no one wants to hear but susan believes
change is possible if people just minded
the speed limit so many lives would be
saved and she hopes by speaking out
she can stop other families from
suffering the same fate
you can't take it back
you know you can't you can't undo it
now of those 24 who died on the roads in
january six were pedestrians like johnny
in nevada now his mom susan worked with
clark county to get this traffic light
here at arby and florida apache
installed in early 2020 so she said that
she can help others stay safe while
crossing this particular street
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now